Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
Hello Walter.
Hi Martin.
I am doing well. How are you doing? I'm
doing fine, thank you. That's good.
So, what have we in store today? I
thought we'd cross the Jordan.
That sounds good. Yes, because, you
know, crossing the Jordan is the type of
going home. Mhm.
And I think many are feeling that it
really is getting time to go home now.
Yes, it's time to get to Canaan.
But
you can't cross the Jordan without the
ark of the covenant.
No, it does to go before you. Mhm.
So, let's open with a word of prayer.
Our heavenly Father, thank you very much
for bringing us together again. Lord, we
ask that you bless our minds and this
discussion and help us to discern the
right from wrong in Jesus' name. Amen.
Typology in the Bible.
If it weren't for that,
it would be a book for a time. Mhm.
But now it is a timeless book.
And uh I think it's time that we looked
at some of the typologies again.
Just to feel secure that we really are
going home. Yeah. Yeah.
And people have to
realize how to
implement the typology
from what happened then to what's
happening now.
Correct.
You know, Martin, when it comes to
typology,
the Bible tells us that we should apply
it. Mhm.
And one of the texts that are very
important for the time or that is very
important for the time we are living in
is 1 Corinthians chapter 10.
Paul says, "Moreover, brethren,
I would not that you should be ignorant
how that all our fathers were under the
cloud
and all passed through the sea
and were all baptized unto Moses in the
cloud and in the sea
and did all eat the same spiritual meat
and did all drink the same spiritual
drink.
For they drank of that spiritual rock
that followed them and that rock was
Christ.
But whenever there's such a positive
statement, there's always a but, right?
Unfortunately.
But with many of them God was not well
pleased.
For they were overthrown in the
wilderness. Now, these things were our
examples to the intent that we should
not lust after evil things as they
lusted.
Neither be ye idolaters
as were some of them.
As it is written, the people sat down to
eat and drink
and rose up to play.
Now,
would you normally consider that
idolatry, Martin?
No.
But this is idolatry, right?
Exactly. All right. So, he's taking it
to our time and he's saying
they were idolaters. And what were they
doing? They were eating,
they were drinking,
and they rose up to play.
So, eating and drinking can be an idol.
Mhm.
There's a right form of eating and
drinking and there's a wrong form of
eating and drinking.
And they rose up to play.
Now,
this is an allusion to the Egyptian
sport.
In the Gilgamesh epic, as we discussed
in in previous lectures,
sport played a very, very important role
and sport was an idol. Mhm.
And as we said before, if that round
object goes into a net or into a hole,
that's the victory of the sun god over
his enemies.
So, there was a religious connotation in
sport and it was a an act of worship.
Mhm.
Now, today, we also have an act of
worship. We even have the raised arms
and everything that goes along with it.
It is an act of worship.
Face painting.
Everything.
Everything. Everything is exactly the
same.
So, food was an idol and sport was an
idol. Neither let us commit fornication.
Now,
this could be literal fornication or it
could be spiritual fornication, right?
As some of them committed
and fell in one day 3 and 20,000.
Neither let us tempt Christ as some of
them also tempted and were destroyed
of the serpents. You know, there's a lot
of information in this in this verse.
This tempting of Christ
and the serpents involved,
uh this has to do with righteousness by
faith. Because when that serpent was
lifted up
and you looked upon it, you were healed.
So, he became sin for us, right? Yeah.
And then there's the question of
murmuring. Neither murmur ye as some of
them also murmured and were destroyed of
the destroyer. Now, all these things
happened unto them for ensamples.
And they are written for our admonition
upon whom the ends of the world are
come. Wherefore, let him that thinketh
he standeth take heed lest he fall.
We are repeating the history of Israel
except that we've had a lot of practice
and we're improving upon whatever they
did, right?
So, this is a very important thing to
ponder.
And we should ask ourselves, what
happened to them?
Why did it happen to them? Mhm. And why
was God not well pleased with them? And
why
were they overthrown in the wilderness?
Lest it happens to us, right?
Correct.
It is for our ensample, so we have to
learn from it.
Correct.
Now, they were all baptized
into Moses, it says, right? So, the
Hebrews
were all baptized into Moses in the
cloud and in the sea. Having been
delivered from slavery to Egypt,
they continued in the wilderness, then
Christ gave them spiritual food and
drink. Mhm.
Also in a physical form. Yes. And that
also served as the type of his body,
right? Yes.
So, the water is a symbol of deliverance
and cleansing, but it's also a symbol of
destruction to the enemies of God.
There's always this double connotation,
right?
So, if you look at water in the in the
Bible and you see Noah's ark,
the world was destroyed by water, Yeah.
but the ark was also borne up by water.
Mhm.
And those that were in it, eight of them
were saved.
Now, the number eight is the number of
Christ.
So, those that are in Christ will be
saved,
but you have to go through this baptism.
Now, these
in the in the type were baptized into
Moses. Mhm.
What does that mean?
Well, he serves as a type of Christ.
And they followed Moses.
Yeah.
In other words, what Moses taught, what
Moses believed, what Moses wrote, that
was their guide.
Of course, it came from God.
Yes.
So, he serves only as a type and he
refers to the prophet that would come
afterwards. Him you must hear.
So, they followed the faith of Moses.
And we must have the faith of Jesus.
Correct. Right?
Yeah. Interesting, right?
Okay. So, the typology is very, very
important. So, Noah's ark is a symbol of
water. Moses' basket. Mhm.
It sustained him and he floated, but
that same water turned to blood Correct.
and was a plague.
And then you had the parting of the Red
Sea.
That was a baptism by water. They passed
through the water.
They came out alive on the other side
and the enemies passed through the water
and ended up dead.
Yeah.
And then there's the crossing of the
Jordan River.
They are examples of God's deliverance
through water.
Now, the Jordan is particularly
interesting
because it also stood on a heap. Yeah.
And they had progressed to a point
where the Ark of the Covenant preceded
them, right?
Yes. And the priest carried it.
And the water were in flood were in
flood at that time.
So, we have to look at all of these
things because they are written as
examples for the time in which we are
living.
So, the Hebrews were all baptized into
Moses and the cloud and in the sea
having been delivered from the slavery
to Egypt.
We have been delivered from the slavery
of sin. Mhm.
And instead of Egypt, we come out of
Babylon.
Correct. All right. So, now there's a
very strong religious connotation.
And they continued in the wilderness and
Christ gave them spiritual food and
drink. That's what we read.
And we are baptized into the death and
resurrection of Christ.
So, the parallels
are very important and the lessons of
their walk apply to us. Correct.
So,
when we are delivered
and we die
in baptism Yes. then we must be dead to
sin but alive to God, right?
Yes.
Romans chapter 6:1-4, "What shall we say
then? Shall we continue in sin that
grace may abound?
God forbid. How shall we that are dead
to sin live any longer therein? Know ye
not
that so many as of us as were baptized
into Jesus Christ
were baptized into his death.
Therefore, we are buried with him in
baptism into death that like as Christ
was raised up from the dead by the glory
of the Father, even so we also should
walk in the newness of life."
Now, Martin, how do you know
whether
you have performed a ritual Mhm. or
whether you've really undergone a total
transformation? By their fruits you
shall know them.
By the fruits.
Now, many of the Israelites
surely believed what Moses was saying,
right? Yes.
And they followed Moses.
They went, yeah. And they were basically
baptized Mhm. into his belief system,
which is the Torah.
And many of them
fell in the wilderness.
Mhm.
So, not all of them had a genuine
conversion. Correct.
And it could it be the same in our time?
Definitely.
Okay.
We are bound
to repeat
what our predecessors did. Correct. So,
Israel refused to believe
that God would be with them. And this
event was the proverbial straw that
broke the camel's back. Numbers 14:22
says that this was the 10th time that
Israel had tested God.
After 10 occasions, it was pretty clear
that this generation of the Israelites
did not have hearts which trusted God.
And so God swore that they would not
enter.
So, if you read Numbers 14:22, it says,
"Because all those men which have seen
my glory and my miracles which I did in
Egypt and in the wilderness and have
tempted me now these 10 times
and have not hearkened unto my voice."
So, was God patient with them?
Definitely. All right.
Very patient. And he's shown even before
this that he's been patient all along
with other people as well. Has he been
patient with us? I hope.
Even longer than with them. Even longer.
Even longer.
So, they passed through the Red Sea.
The waters stood on a heap.
They were baptized as it were into
Moses. In other words, they followed
him.
He put his stuff there, they followed.
They were basically baptized into his
faith.
Passed out through the other side. The
enemy was destroyed.
And they were overjoyed by their
deliverance, right? Yeah. And then they
went
into the desert
where God had said, "I will prove them
whether they will walk in my law or
not." Correct. Now, Martin,
how could God have said that if the law
had not yet been given?
He wouldn't have been able to. But he
said it, right?
Okay.
So, Exodus chapter 16:35 says, "And the
children of Israel did eat manna 40
years
until they came to a land inhabited.
They did eat manna
until they came unto the borders of the
land of Canaan, 40 years."
Paul called it spiritual food. Mhm. It
was also physical food. Yeah. But they
should have learned a lesson with it.
Correct.
Cuz there were many lessons associated.
How long it would last.
A miracle every Friday that it lasted
two days. It would not see corruption.
Christ's body didn't see corruption. The
parallels are very very beautiful.
And then in Numbers 11:18-20,
it says, "And say thou unto the people,
sanctify yourselves against tomorrow and
you shall eat flesh."
So, it was a type that we need to watch
out for. Mhm.
The people craved the flesh pots of
Egypt.
But not only the flesh pots.
They also craved the leeks and the
onions and all of Is there anything
wrong with leeks and onions?
No. I have a whole lot of them growing
in my garden. Mhm.
Nothing wrong with leeks and onions,
right?
It's the palate that we're talking
about. The association.
But particularly the flesh was a
problem.
And the Lord said, "For you have wept in
the ears of the Lord saying, who shall
give us flesh to eat for it was well
with us in Egypt.
Therefore, the Lord will give you flesh
and you shall eat. You shall not eat 1
day nor 2 days nor 5 days nor 10 days
nor 20 days
but even a whole month
until it come out of your nostrils
and it be loathsome unto you
because you have that you have despised
the Lord which is among you
and have wept before him saying, why
came we forth out of Egypt?"
Now, Martin, was this the first time
that they got meat or the second time?
Second time.
Did this happen anything bad happen the
first time? No.
God showed them that he was displeased
because they murmured against Moses, but
he didn't do anything. No.
He didn't reprimand them with a plague.
No.
But in this on this occasion and while
the flesh was yet between their teeth,
ere it was chewed
the wrath of the Lord was kindled
against the people and the Lord smote
the people with a very great plague.
Martin, if we take
the health message how long have we had
it?
170 years.
It's a long time, right? Mhm.
And has God been very tolerant when it
comes to the craving for flesh food and
perverted palates?
Yes, definitely. He has, right?
Now, we live in a country
where flesh food is
the ultimate diet, right?
Mhm.
And anything else is considered garnish.
Yes.
And within the church, we have the same
problem. Mhm. And God has been very
tolerant and we have statements in the
Spirit of Prophecy which say
uh meat eating is not a test of
fellowship.
In other words, I can't say I don't want
to associate you with you because you
eat meat.
But we also have statements which say
that your spiritual discernment will be
clouded if you partake in flesh foods.
And we have very strong statements which
say that you cannot trust
what comes from a pulpit
if it is associated with the consumption
of flesh foods.
So, it's a very important issue. And God
in his mercy has tried to train our
people Mhm. to move in the right
direction. The same that he did with
Israel.
The same. He was very tolerant, right?
And so he tolerated it. And it's not a
test of fellowship. Not at all.
But this second time, it's associated
with a plague.
Now, Martin, if the type existed
then what's the probability that
there'll be an antitype?
100%.
So, if the tolerance has lasted until
now, is it possible that sometime in the
future
or even now already
that that tolerance, that protection,
shall I put it that way,
is removed, not because God is
vindictive, but because we are so
stubborn.
Definitely. You think so? Yeah. We've
even showed some of the quotes
previously. Correct, and we'll show some
more.
We'll show some more because it's
This is a very important subject, a very
important point. Yes, and people people
don't want to gross
that what you eat and what you drink
is also associated with your moral
choices.
It's amazing to me, again, it's putting
the Bible
and science
to
weigh unto each other.
And they have to decide who they're
going to trust. Okay.
Now,
when you look at the statistics that
they're handing out in the world as to
people who are succumbing
to the diseases which are so prevalent
in the world today,
it's mainly elderly people
who have degenerative diseases already.
So, already they're not in good shape,
right?
They have cardiovascular diseases, they
have arthritis, they have
uh
many, many problems, and they are
immunocompromised.
Then the other category that is
mentioned is the obese people.
They have a problem.
So, it seems to me that if you do not
adhere to the principles of health,
you fall into a higher risk category
when it comes to the modern-day plagues.
Yes. So, is there perhaps a parallel
that we can draw out here? Um
definitely.
So, what is your suggestion for the
people of God considering the history of
Israel? Well, my suggestion is as in
also one of the previous uh what's the
process that we showed,
weigh your science that you trust on
against the Bible. If the science
correlate and
agrees, then you're on the right track,
then follow that. But if it's in
conflict with the Bible,
like we've shown here, disregard it.
Even though the world will tell you that
is the correct one. Correct. So, the
world is heavily into uh animal protein
as the best source.
And that comes from a totally erroneous
concept
where they considered that animal
protein was of a higher quality
than plant protein
and was to be the primary source of
protein because of the amino acid
composition,
which is a complete protein, whereas
plants generally are incomplete
proteins.
But of course, you're not supposed to be
a
monoculture
uh individual. You don't only eat one
kind of food.
So, we discussed in in one of the last
ones, the niacin shortage,
when you don't have bread and wheat, for
example.
So, if you only have corn, you can have
a niacin deficiency, but if you have
wheat along with it, you don't have a
deficiency, and you don't have these
diseases. So, God provided a vast
variety,
and he wants us to enjoy that variety.
But modern society brushes that variety
aside and concentrates on
animal protein.
And what are we having tonight, Martin?
Is it going to be beef, or is it going
to be chicken?
No, it will be beef because chicken is a
vegetable.
You're quite right. That was my argument
in the old days.
But just think about it.
That is
what people say. I've I've never heard
when somebody says,
"What are we having for supper tonight?"
that the person will say, "We are having
potatoes."
or we are having broccoli,
or we are having carrots.
Never. It's always beef or chicken or
lamb or pork or whatever it is, right?
That's the supper. What's the rest then?
Add-on. It's It's garnish, right?
So,
this is a typology
which we are well on the way to
fulfilling. And I believe that the
second portion,
where
the wrong type of diet and the wrong
type of craving
was associated with the people of God,
it was associated with the plague.
Here it's quite clear that God sent the
plague.
But it could just also be interpreted
God permitted the plague in the end
times, right?
Exactly. Exactly. Okay. So, that just as
a warning to God's people that lifestyle
plays a very important part in the end
time besides the spiritual aspects.
Now, I think we've read this one before,
but because it is so seldom quoted in
the world,
I thought it would be a good thing just
to read it again because repetition is a
very important thing.
Yeah, we've learned this from our um
news media that's continually repeating
certain things, and people are getting
accustomed to it. Uh so, are you
following a good example here, Martin?
I don't know if it's a good example.
The sanctification set forth in the
scripture embraces the entire being,
spirit, soul, and body. Paul prayed for
the Thessalonians that their whole
spirit and soul and body
be preserved blameless unto the coming
of our Lord Jesus Christ. Again, he
writes to the believers,
"I beseech you therefore, brethren, by
the mercies of God that you present your
bodies a living sacrifice holy
acceptable unto God." Quoting Romans
12:1.
The Jews were commanded to offer in
sacrifice to God only such animals as
were free from disease or blemish. So,
Christians
are required to preserve all their
powers in the best possible condition
for the Lord's service.
Says Peter, "Abstain from fleshly lusts,
which war against the soul."
The word of God will make but a feeble
impression upon those whose faculties
are benumbed by any sinful
gratification.
The heart cannot preserve
consecration to God while the animal
appetites and passions are indulged at
the expense of health and life.
Paul writes to the Corinthians, "Let us
cleanse ourselves from all filthiness of
the flesh and spirit, perfecting
holiness in the fear of God."
And with the fruits of the spirit, love,
joy, peace, long-suffering, gentleness,
goodness, faith, meekness, he closes
temperance.
Now, Martin, people will say, "Well, we
only eat clean meat, clean food, clean
animals."
And
I gave a number of lectures a few years
ago already about the condition of the
meat industry,
what animals are fed, how they are
raised.
And
that if you look at the principles in
the Bible and you see
what are the criteria that are attached
to an unclean animal,
you will find, number one, that all
carnivores are unclean.
Every single one. There is not one clean
carnivore.
Only herbivores are classed as clean.
And then only such herbivores
that do not recycle their food from the
rectum. In other words, that are not
coprophagic.
So, a rabbit and a horse
that have cecal fermentation, which is
at the end of the intestine, and pass it
through a second time, are unclean by
virtue of the toxins which accumulate in
them. And there were experiments that
were done
where they took the the extracts from
the flesh of unclean animals versus
clean animals,
and looked at the effect on the growth
of, let's say, a bean variety.
And if it was a clean animal, it was not
stunted, but if it was an unclean
animal, it stunted the growth.
So, the same will happen to you, right?
So, God tried to lead his people back to
a vegetarian lifestyle. We've had this
message for well over a century.
And many of our people ignore it.
And sooner or later,
the more they lust it,
the more immunocompromised they will be,
and the more likely is the is that they
could succumb to a plague. This is
pretty direct language, but this is the
way it goes.
Now, today,
I don't believe there is anything like a
clean animal left on the planet.
Because even if their diet
is free range,
they are still subject to zoonotic
diseases. In other words, diseases that
affect the animal which are now
trans-specific.
So, in the old days, you had bird flu
and it affected birds.
Now, bird flu affects humanity.
In the old days, you had swine flu and
it affected swine.
Now, it affects humanity. In the old
days, you had foot and mouth disease.
They call these viral diseases.
Now, it affects humanity.
There is no such thing today anymore, in
my opinion, as a clean animal. Even in
the best of circumstances.
Because you can have a free range
chicken, but it can still get a viral
disease, right?
Which is transmissible to humanity.
And we've had this message which says
that disease is increasing in proportion
to the wickedness of men. The time will
come when there will be no safety in
partaking of any animal product, whether
it be dairy or meat or any one of those.
We've had this message.
Has God given us alternatives? Yes.
So, those that want substitutes which
taste like the real thing.
Are there enough of them on the on the
shelves?
Yes, or you can prepare your own way.
You can prepare it for yourself. So,
you will come short in nothing. No.
There are statements which says God will
give culinary skill
to his people in different parts of the
world.
So, Martin, if you really are a food
junkie,
you can look at the foods in the various
parts of the world
and we have access to
recipes
galore.
Correct. You can punch in Indian food
and get Indian varieties. You can get
Eastern foods. You can get anything
under the sun.
And you can have a culinary experience
without once putting a morsel of flesh
or animal derived food into your mouth.
We have no excuse, right?
No, that's true.
Do our people still make excuses? Yes.
Uh, is God well pleased with those that
still make excuses? No.
Because, as we've shown, God's number
one reason is to get your mind clear.
Yes. And secondary,
he wants you to be healthy as well.
Correct.
So, he cares for both of them.
So, we read in the spirit of prophecy
that this branch of the Lord's work, the
health message, in other words, has not
received due attention.
And through this neglect, much has been
lost. If the church would manifest a
greater interest in the reforms
through which God himself is seeking to
fit them for his coming, their influence
would be far greater than it is now.
You know, Martin,
that's an incredible statement. Do you
mean there are so many that are
neglecting the health message
that their influence has become stunted?
Correct. It's sad.
God has spoken to his people and he
designs that they shall hear and obey
his voice. Although the health reform is
not the third angel's message, it is
closely connected with it. And those who
proclaim the message should teach health
reform also. It is a subject that we
must understand in order to be prepared
for the events
that are close upon us. So, Martin, how
important do you think it is?
Very important. It's It's very
important. It's the right arm of the
third angel's message.
So, that means it's going to have to
influence choice.
And it's going to influence your choice.
And if you just run along and don't
change anything, you will be swept away
because, according to the spirit of
prophecy, you won't have discernment.
It's strong words,
but if God said it, we must trust that
it's going to be like this.
He says in Psalms,
"They lusted and he sent leanness into
their soul." Now, this is not God
punishing you. This is you punishing
yourself. Through a choice.
Through a choice.
Correct.
All right. Now, we could go into the
physiology of what the animal product
do. Animal fats clog the system.
Animal fats clog the way in which your
brain functions. If you have the wrong
type of food without the
complex carbohydrates, then you don't
have the correct brain food. Your brain
functions on pure
carbohydrate and it needs the right
combinations. All of these factors
affect your thinking.
And and it's actually very
um
elementary, very easy. You read, God
says, "Don't eat the fat."
Correct.
Of the animals. Of the animals. He don't
have a He doesn't give a reason. He
says, "Don't eat it." But now you've got
science that's trying to prove that fat
is good for you. Yes. Animal fat. But
what kind of fat? You see, fat, animal
fat,
consists of stearic acid.
And that's a saturated fat.
Now, some plant fats are also saturated
fats, like coconut oil.
But that's not stearic acid. It's
palmitic acid.
And the interesting thing is palmitic
acid
has totally different metabolism to
stearic acid.
It is a fat that is easily utilized and
converted in the human body, whereas
stearic acid is stored
and stored in the blood vessels. It
affects your oxygen transport. It
affects your cardiovascular system. The
differences are absolutely amazing.
So, the plant fats, the ones that we
should consume,
should be
the plant fats that are saturated would
be like coconut oil, etc.
Monounsaturated
fats,
we will find them in nuts and seeds and
in olives. The oil as it is in the olive
is most wholesome. Correct.
And that just brings me back to the
point that I made earlier.
The Bible says, "Stay away from fat."
Yes. This animal fat. Because where he
said, "Don't eat the fat," he was
talking about animal fat. Correct.
So, if your science is not correlating
with that, it's false science. Correct.
That's That's easy as that. When the
widow's jar was filled with oil,
uh, was it animal oil or was it olive
oil? Olive oil. It was olive oil. So,
there are many, many places in the Bible
where there are just statements and
science has corroborated them. There's
not a scientist in the world
that knows his oats that will recommend
animal fat.
So, Martin, one of the lessons
that the Israelites had to learn, that
were written for our example,
is the one on diet, right?
They They really struggled with that
one.
And thereafter, once they came into
Canaan, God permitted them to go in
their way,
but he said,
"I don't want you to transgress my
health laws." Yes. And he gave Moses a
very specific set of health laws.
And had they adhered to it,
they would have been spiritually
discerning. Correct.
Now,
God says that he was not well pleased
with that generation and we'll look at
some of these issues. And finally,
when they came to the borders of Canaan
and they were going to cross the into
into Canaan,
they sent out 12 spies.
Now, Martin, how many of those spies
came back with a good report? Only two.
Only two. Joshua and Caleb.
And 10 of them had a
bad report, right?
Now, let's unpack that a little bit.
So, Joshua and Caleb
were baptized into Moses. Yes.
Is that correct?
So, whatever Moses wrote, whatever Moses
believed, they had assimilated it.
And the food that they ate was not just
food to them, it was also spiritual
food. So, they grew in faith.
They saw what happened at the Red Sea.
They saw what happened in the wilderness
and they accepted the lessons.
And they were two of the spies that were
sent out, Joshua and Caleb. Did they
believe what Moses believed?
Yes. Did they therefore believe that
what God had promised, he could also
perform? Yes.
Did they base their knowledge of what
they believed also on past experience?
Correct. Yeah. They saw what he had done
to the Egyptians.
They believed he would do it to the
Canaanites.
So, when they saw the giants,
Mhm. did their knees buckle? No.
No.
stood strong. Because what happened to
the Egyptians? They never even lifted a
sword, right?
Exactly.
And they said when they came back, we
are well able
to take it.
And it is a land flowing with milk and
honey.
You know what's interesting to me? I
don't think it was Joshua and Caleb that
carried that bunch of grapes between
them.
I think it was one of the other 10.
And in spite of it,
they were opposed.
Now,
did Joshua and Caleb bring a good
testimony? Yes. They had a positive
testimony, so it was a good testimony.
They brought a good testimony. Was the
testimony that they brought in harmony
with what Moses had written?
Yes. So, what Moses was written was
known as the law. Mhm. The Torah, right?
Yes.
So, what they believed was the law.
And they had a testimony which was in
harmony with the law. Correct. So, do
you think they believed in the law and
the testimony proved it? Yes. So, could
we in a sense say, Martin, that the two
spies stand for the law and the
testimony? Yes. Mhm? Mhm. Definitely.
And the 10?
Did they believe the Torah, that God was
going to do this for them? There were
certain portions that they believed, but
they didn't believe that God will
deliver them.
The giants are too big. We can't We
can't go and fight against those. Forget
it. It's a lost cause.
Yes, the land is like a land flowing
with milk and honey,
but you guys have deceived us. We want
to go back to Egypt.
Yeah.
Didn't they say that? It's going to be
too tough. Martin is there listening
then.
Oh, definitely.
All right. Now, what was the ratio?
The ratio is pretty scary, right?
10 to 2. 10 to 2.
And
when they brought a good report, those
two, didn't they the people pick up
stones? Yes. They wanted to stone them
to death. And they sided with whom?
With with the 10.
Yes.
It's interesting with I think I have the
quote in here somewhere where
the spirit of prophecy says, "Even if
only if 10 had brought a good report,
the people would still have sided with
the
with those that brought the bad report,
even if they were only two."
That's true. Okay. So, what does that
tell us about the spiritual preparedness
of the majority of the people?
They're not ready.
They're not ready to take it, right?
ready to go into Canaan. They're not
ready.
And they were sent back. Yes. They'd
already wandered for 2 years.
Now, they were sent back
make a total of 40 years. So, they had
to wander another 38 years.
Yeah.
Without reaching Canaan.
All right. Now,
those two spies,
if they represent the law and the
testimony,
and then they had to go back because
nobody listened.
Do we have anything similar that
happened within
the Advent movement?
Yes.
Could they have gone in at a particular
stage?
Mhm.
Mhm? 1888. Yes.
Now, tell me, Martin, just for
interest's sake.
How many
in 1888
had a good report?
Probably two.
Two?
Wasn't it Jones and Wagner? Yes. How
many is that? Two.
Jones and Wagner, one. That's two,
right?
Two had a good report.
How many picked up stones?
The rest.
The rest. Yeah. So, have we repeated
that history? Yes. We've We've met the
antitype. We've met the antitype and
we've gone back a one ring. Uh-huh.
Fortunately for you and me, because
we're the next generation, right? That
could come in. You're
even a generation after me, right?
Yeah.
So,
interesting, right? Very interesting.
Two brought a good report.
Mhm.
Gives you quite a
eye-opener of where we are in the stream
of time.
It's fascinating. And that was in 1888,
Martin. That's a long time ago, right?
So, God was not pleased.
No.
And many of those had to fall in the
wilderness.
And then there was a second attempt to
go in. But let's just read here,
Patriarchs and Prophets. The Canaanites
had filled up the measure of their
iniquity and the Lord would no longer
bear with them.
His protection being removed, they would
be an easy prey.
By the covenant of God, the land was
insured to Israel.
But the false report of the unfaithful
spies was accepted
and through it the whole congregation
were deluded.
The traitors had done their work. If
only the two men had brought the evil
report and all the 10 had encouraged
them to possess the land in the name of
the Lord, they would still have taken
the advice of the two in preference to
the 10
because of their wicked unbelief.
But there were only two advocating the
right, while 10 were on the side of
rebellion. We've repeated that history
verbatim.
Yeah.
Except they weren't called Caleb
and Joshua. They were called Jones and
Wagner.
The unfaithful spies were loud in
denunciation of Caleb and Joshua,
and the cry was raised to stone them.
The insane mob seized missiles with
which to slay those faithful men. They
rushed forward with yells of madness.
When suddenly the stones dropped from
their hands, a hush fell upon them and
they shook with fear.
God had interposed to check their
murderous design. The glory of his
presence like a flaming light
illuminated the tabernacle. All the
people beheld the signal of the Lord, a
mightier one than they had revealed
himself and none dared continue their
resistance. The spies who brought the
evil report crouched terror-stricken
and with bated breath sought their
tents.
Martin, we are living
in an antitypical world right now. Mhm.
And when we look at the world and the
information that is coming from our
ranks,
is there a great majority that is
shouting that we are living in the end
times, that we are going home, and if we
stand true to principles, we are well
able
to enter into the land or is it a
minority? Minority.
Unfortunately. Two out of 12?
Yep. Do you think it's possible? Yep.
The ratio still stands. Do you think the
others are shouting vehemently against
them, calling them all kinds of
derogatory names?
Mhm. Is it possible?
Definitely. Writing articles in their
little spiritual magazines against those
that are
trying to raise the alarm that the time
has come?
Yep.
It's happening. Do you think uh camps
are forming where they're saying that
these will be a danger to society and to
the church and we should pick up stones
and get rid of them? Yes. Do you think
it's possible?
Definitely.
Martin,
are you trying to make me nervous?
No.
But I still say we are well able.
If we see if we take the type,
then we have nothing nothing to fear in
the antitype if you're on the side of
God.
So, if you're on the side of God, when
Christ comes
and there is this heavenly illumination,
there may be
some of them will want to run to their
tents.
Correct.
So,
how convinced are you, Martin,
that we have reached the culmination
point of the antitype?
I'm 100% convinced. You are? Mhm.
So, two entered, Joshua and Caleb.
Only two. Mhm. Of that vast crowd.
This is now the second time at the
Jordan.
Correct. So, now after the 38 years,
not one of those 10 spies
went
entered in. Not one. That's a very
serious issue, right?
Okay.
Now, when they got to the border the
second time,
how many spies did they send in? Just
two. Just two, not 12. No.
That didn't work so well last time,
right?
No. Now, there's an antitype there,
which is fascinating. In other words,
these people were now ready to enter in.
Yeah. Okay? They believed the law, they
believed the testimony,
and two spies went in. Wasn't necessary
to send 12.
And two represents the law and the
testimony. Correct. They believed it.
So, if we look at the outcome
of what happened to those two that
believed in the law
and a good testimony. When they came
back,
did they bring a good testimony? Yes.
Yes. Very good. They spoke about the
conversations they heard and that they
were surely going to be able to do this.
And they met this lady, Rahab. Mhm.
Right?
Now, Rahab
was a prostitute.
And she lived on the wall.
Now, in the Bible,
a wall around the city is the
protection. Mhm. And the symbol that God
uses for his church, the wall around it
represents the law. Yes.
Now, Rahab lived
on the wall or in the wall, because the
walls were very thick and they had
apartments in them and she was
associated with the wall. So,
typologically, could we say
that Rahab
and is a woman and a woman represents a
church and it is a church that was
apostate?
Cuz that's represented as a prostitute,
right? Yes. If we had to make an
antitype out of it.
So, even in a place like Jericho, which
was an idolatrous city,
there was a woman who still had some
connection with the wall.
And the promise was made to her
that her whole
family and anyone who came to her house
would be saved. Correct.
So, in the end of time,
will those churches that weren't aware
of the law and the testimony
will eventually, some of them will come
to the conclusion that they must side
with the people of God? Yes. And they
put a crimson lint out, right? Mhm.
Which represents the sacrifice of
Christ. Yeah.
Which means that they accepted the
atonement of Jesus Christ and the two
witnesses, the law and the testimony,
that came to them Yes. and joined
God's people, right? Mhm. How firmly did
they join God's people?
Well, if you go to Ruth, chapter 4, it
says, "And Salmon
begat Boaz." It doesn't say in this
verse who the mother of Boaz was, but
who was she? Rahab.
Rahab, the prostitute.
And then who was Salmon?
He could have been one of the spies,
right? Yes.
So, one of the spies
married Rahab.
And they begat Boaz and Boaz begat Obed
and Obed begat Jesse and Jesse begat
David. Mhm.
Now, Boaz married who?
Ruth.
All right, and Ruth was a Moabitess.
Mhm. All right? Mhm. So, here are
sister churches, let's put it that way,
because the Moabites came from
Lot. Yeah.
The daughters of Lot. Mhm. So, they were
also
apostate and prostitutes, etc. But some
of them said, like Ruth, "Your God will
be my God and your people will be my
people." Yes. That's coming out of her,
my people, and joining yourself to those
who believe the law and the testimony.
Mhm.
So, it's interesting
that Christ incorporates
all of these into his own genealogy.
Mhm.
Right?
So, that means that from every corner
Amazing. The typology is so stunning to
me. And the only thing that they have to
do to be incorporated there is to
believe the law and the testimony.
Correct. Did Rahab believe the spies?
Yes. Ah, so she believed the testimony.
Correct. And she believed the law,
because she'd seen what the people had
been through. They knew everything that
happened to the Egyptians, etc. And
there was no heart in them. Yeah.
So, I mean, an amazing, amazing typology
in this story.
But then again, let's read what it says
in the spirit of prophecy.
A few miles beyond the river, just
opposite the place where the Israelites
were encamped, was the large and
strongly fortified city of Jericho.
This city was virtually the key to the
whole country and it would present a
formidable obstacle to the success of
Israel.
Joshua, therefore, sent two young men as
spies to visit this city and ascertain
something as to its population,
its resources, and strength of its
fortifications.
The inhabitants of the city,
terrified and suspicious, were
constantly on the alert
and the messengers were in great danger.
Martin, do you think as we enter the
second time now into Canaan,
because surely we're going there the
second time, right?
Definitely.
Uh do you think there will be great
danger? Yes. Mhm. Will the city look
extremely fortified? Yes.
And
this city has to be taken down, right?
Mhm.
And the Bible talks much about a city
that is an enemy city in the book of
Revelation, right? Good.
So, these people were actually terrified
and suspicious, so were constantly on
the alert and the messengers were in
great danger.
They were, however, preserved by Rahab,
a woman of Jericho, at the peril of her
own life.
In return for her kindness, they gave
her a promise of protection when the
city should be taken.
The spies returned in safety with the
tidings, quote,
"Truly the Lord has delivered into our
hands all the land and even all the
inhabitants of the country do faint
because of us."
Is there an antitype?
Definitely. Even though the odds look
terribly against us, right? Yeah, yeah.
The There will be a small minority, but
the people will be terrified. In the
end, because when they see the signs
fulfilling,
they will know that they have been
deceived, right?
That's maybe a good reason why not to
always stand with the majority.
Correct.
It had been declared to them in Jericho,
"We have heard how the Lord dried up the
water of the Red Sea for you
when you came out of Egypt
and what you did unto the kings of the
Amorites that were on the other side of
Jordan, Sihon and Og, whom you utterly
destroyed. And as soon as we had heard
these things, our hearts did melt,
neither did there remain any more
courage in any man because of you.
For the Lord your God, he is God in
heaven above and in the earth beneath."
So, they might pick up those stones and
pick up those swords to put an end to
you, but God will intervene.
So, Martin,
the story about the healing of the
at the pool of Bethesda
in John, chapter 5,
from verse 1 to 9,
is very interesting.
After this, there was a feast of the
Jews
and Jesus went up to Jerusalem. Now,
there is at Jerusalem by the sheep
market a pool,
which is called in the Hebrew tongue
Bethesda, having five porches.
It's very interesting, it's the sheep
market. Mhm. So, it's where they sold
sacrificial animals.
And it had five porches and five is the
the number of humanity. You have five
senses, etc.
And in these lay a great multitude of
impotent folk,
of blind, halt, withered, waiting for
the moving of the water.
For an angel went down at a certain
season into the pool and troubled the
water.
Whosoever then first after the troubling
of the water stepped in was made whole
of whatever disease he had and a certain
man was there which had an infirmity 30
and 8 years.
Now, Martin, this is a very interesting
story with a very interesting spiritual
application.
Some of the Bible translations say that
this portion about the stirring of the
water shouldn't be there.
And they don't agree that the King James
included that, for example. Mhm.
Which is a tragedy, of course, because
it's sad when they remove certain
portions. And the spiritual lesson,
after you know what it is, No. that
emphasizes the tragedy that they want to
leave it out.
Exactly. So, if this portion tells about
the story, it doesn't mean that this is
true,
that the people were healed when they
got out. This is what the people
believed. Yes. All right?
So, they had developed a belief system
which was based on certain events which
had to take place.
You know, we have in the world today a
very similar religious system.
Where God is healing certain people
apparently when they pass through
certain waters or go to certain
evangelistic meetings, etc., etc.
Where people fall down, get up, throw
their crutches away, and next week you
see them walking with their crutches.
And uh
it's a it's a belief system
of well, if you can only do this. If I
could only go to Lourdes
and get some holy water on me,
I might be cured of whatever malady I
have. Yeah. If I could only make a
pilgrimage to the Vatican.
If I could only see an apparition.
If I could only go to Guadalupe to see
whether I could get healed there, etc.,
etc.
Or if I could only go to the healers in
the Philippines
that will put their hand without surgery
into me and remove a tumor, then I would
be fine. This is the type of religion
that the world has.
It is a miracle
awaiting religion. And because of the
miracles, people were deceived. Correct.
Says the Bible. So, they had a form of
religion.
And here this man was lying there
together with a lot of impotent, blind,
halt, and withered people.
And he was lying there for 38 years.
Now, that number is not an arbitrary
number. No.
The children of Israel had wandered 2
years, they came to the border.
And because of unbelief, they were
turned back. Exactly.
And they had to wander another 38 years.
Mhm. This was a symbol of the state of
Israel that was in exactly the same
place as the children of Israel were
that had wandered. And they were
impotent, they didn't know where to go,
they were blind, they were halt, and
they were withered. Their religion was
withered.
It was based on fable Exactly. and
fantasy. It was spiritual formation at
its best.
It was an empty religion of form. Yeah.
And Jesus, ignoring the stupidity of the
water,
went and asked him,
"Do you want to be healed?"
When Jesus saw him lying knew that he
had been now a long time in this case,
he says unto him, "Wilt thou be made
whole?"
The impotent man answered him, "Sir, I
have no man
when the water is troubled to put me in
the pool, but while I'm coming, another
step is down before me." Jesus said to
him, "Rise, take up your bed and walk."
Did Jesus say to him, "Come, let me help
you into the pool?"
No. No, he distanced himself from the
stupidity of that belief, right?
Correct.
Now, do we have the world's churches in
the same state?
Do you think that they are
impotent, blind, halt, and withered?
Yeah.
Mhm?
And we're about to enter into Canaan. He
was there 38 years. It was time to go
home. Mhm.
Right? Correct. Do you think it's time
for us to go home? Yes, definitely.
Have we wandered long enough in this
wilderness? Yes. Are we going to send
out 12 or only two spies? Two. Only the
law and the testimony, and that's it,
right?
And we're going to go across that that
Jordan.
And immediately the man was made whole
because his faith wasn't based on
liturgy.
It was based in a faith
in what Jesus had promised and what the
Bible had promised.
And this is the kind of healing that we
need.
So, this halt man,
this impotent,
withered
human being,
spiritually,
religiously
withered.
He didn't have the faith of Abraham,
right?
Martin, I find it interesting that if
you go
and you look at Abraham and you look at
the promises to Abraham,
that there are certain parallels which
we need to take note of.
So, I just want to go there because
there were seven promises with blessings
that were given to Abraham on a
condition. Yeah, correct.
And we read it in Genesis chapter 12
verse 1 to 3. And he is the father of
them that believe, and he's also the
father of spiritual Israel.
Now, the Lord had said unto Abraham,
"Get thee out of thy country and from
thy kindred and from thy father's house
unto a land that I will show thee."
Now, Martin,
that's quite a tall order.
Get out of your country.
The country represents the world. Yeah.
We have to come out of this world.
Right? Yes.
From your kindred.
Out of your family. Mhm.
In other words, even out of your
religious family, you have to come out
of Babylon. Yes.
And from your father's house, there will
be separated separation even on a filial
level. Mhm.
Unto a land that I will show thee.
Now, to us that is the heavenly Canaan.
Correct.
Now, Martin, isn't it surprising to you
that so many of the churches are jumping
onto the climate bandwagon trying to fix
this world because this is where their
heart is?
No, it boggles my mind.
Have they come out? No. Or are they
trying to fix what's left? Trying to fix
it.
Isn't that a problem? Yeah.
Most of these religions and people are
trying to build a kingdom here with this
fallen world. With this fallen world.
Where there's a better country that God
will show us, right?
And then it says, "And I will make thee
a great nation." That's one promise.
"I will bless thee."
"I will make thy name great." That's the
third promise. "Thou shalt be a
blessing."
Fourth promise. "And I will bless them
that bless thee." Fifth promise. "Curse
them that curse thee." Sixth promise.
"And in thee all the families of the
earth will be blessed." There were seven
promises.
Seven promises which were of a personal
nature and of a corporate nature.
So, Martin, the promises are dependent
upon the fact that he has to leave
everything behind. Yeah.
Did God say to him, "Abraham, go and fix
what is in your place, and then I will
make you happy?" No. I'll give you a
truly human life. No. Which is,
you know, what Catholicism promises you,
right? A truly human life. All these
other um
Christian denominations that say we have
to get rid of all this evil so that we
can have this heaven on earth. No, you
have to come out. Get out of this.
Because I'm going to show you another
place.
Now, seven blessings for Abraham.
And there are seven blessings in the
book of Revelation.
Now, the first one is, "Blessed is he
that readeth and they that hear the
words of this prophecy
and keep those things that are written
therein, for the time is at hand."
That's the first blessing
to God's end-time people.
"Please study the book of Revelation.
Study study the prophecies of the end
time.
Incorporate them, and I will bless you."
Yes.
In other words, the antitypical Calebs
and Joshuas that believe in the law and
the testimony and take this promise to
heart and study the signs of the times,
what are the other 10 doing to them?
Picking up stones.
Isn't that incredible?
Well, it is typology, so it has to
happen. They're picking up stones,
right?
So, they're calling them all kinds of
names
Mhm.
and saying that they are stirring up the
people. Yeah.
And we have to stone them, we have to
get rid of them. And we'll write little
articles in our little magazines and
tell everybody to please pick up stones
and silence these people. Mhm. Cuz
they're going to be a danger to society
at every level. Mhm.
But the Bible says, "Blessed is he that
reads and studies the book of Revelation
Mhm.
and takes it to heart."
In other words, they will have to give
the trumpet a certain sound, they will
have to warn against the mark of the
beast, they will have to warn against
the beast of Revelation chapter 13 and
the prostitute of Revelation 17, and
they can tell them that there is a city
coming, and that there will be a
destruction of this world, and a new
world will be created.
Correct. They must prepare the people to
enter Canaan.
The heavenly one. Correct.
And they will be stoned for it.
And they will be stoned for it. Correct.
And then if you go to chapter 14 verse
13 and I heard a voice from heaven
saying unto me, "Write, blessed are the
dead which die in the Lord from
henceforth."
"Yes," says the spirit, "that they may
rest from their labors and their works
do follow them."
So, if you have taken this to heart and
you are preaching this message,
even if you die,
you're not dead. No. You're still
blessed. Correct. But you have to be
in this mode. You have to give the
trumpet a certain sound.
Because blessed are the dead which die
in the Lord from henceforth.
That means everybody who has
internalized the message, accepted it
and preached it. Correct.
It doesn't matter when they die. So,
even if a stone hits you, Martin, it
doesn't matter, right?
No.
Behold, I come as a thief. Blessed is he
that watches and keepeth his garments
lest he walk naked and see his shame.
Now, we're going to have a look at that
in a little closer detail in a moment.
But
we've spoken about this so many times.
What does it mean to come as a thief?
Maybe there's another aspect that we've
missed, right?
Mhm. Let's look at that in a moment.
But you definitely want the right robe
of righteousness.
Definitely. Without that, you are
covered in your own sin. Correct. So,
there's no room for perfectionism here.
Only the righteousness of Christ.
That's it.
And then there's this other one and he
says unto me, "Write, blessed are they
which are called unto the marriage
supper of the Lamb." And he has said
unto me, "These are the true sayings of
God."
That marriage supper,
those 10 virgins, there's another lesson
there, right?
Yeah.
Blessed and holy is he that has part in
the first resurrection on such the
second death has no power.
But there shall be priests of God and of
Christ and shall reign with him a
thousand years, Martin. If you want to
have this blessing, you must understand
the
millennium. Correct. Now, is the
millennium going to take place here on
earth like the world believes?
No, it can't. It can't.
Because the Lord will come, send his
angels, you will meet him in the sky,
he'll take you to the sea of glass and
he'll take you to the celestial city.
Exactly. So, and the seven plagues would
have destroyed whatever is on here. Now,
would you have understood that if you
hadn't read the book of Revelation?
No.
Because that's the only place where it
defines it exactly for you, the
difference between the first
resurrection, the second resurrection,
the millennium in between and what
happens during that millennium while the
people of God are taken away. You must
study the book of Revelation.
Exactly.
No, we mustn't talk about that. We
should only talk about love, right?
Mhm.
If you can't find the love in the book
of Revelation, then you won't find it in
the rest of the Bible.
You won't find it elsewhere. And anyway,
blessed are are they that read the book
and take it to heart.
And then, behold, I come quickly.
Blessed is he that keepeth the sayings
of the prophecy of this book.
Is there progression here? Mhm.
There's a progression, right? And some
of those that have preached this message
will have fallen asleep.
Blessed are they. Exactly. They're just
waiting in the dust to be called forth,
right?
And blessed are they that do his
commandments. That's like like the
ultimate cherry on top, right?
That they may have the right to the tree
of life and may enter in through the
gates into the city. It's no wonder that
Satan hates this verse and perverts it
in all the modern translations. It is
horrific what has happened has happened
to this verse. And isn't it amazing how
happy everybody is with a change?
So, here is a very interesting
progression of seven blessings for the
end-time people of God.
There were seven blessings at the
beginning for Abraham.
Yeah.
Now, there's also a blessing on
watching.
If we go to Matthew 24 from verse 42 to
46, "Watch therefore,
for you know not what hour the Lord doth
come. But know this,
that if the goodman of the house had
known in what watch the thief would
come,
he would have watched and would not have
suffered his house to be broken up.
Therefore, be ye also ready, for in such
an hour as you think not the Son of man
cometh. Who then is a faithful and wise
servant
whom his lord has made ruler over his
household to give them meat in due
season?
Blessed is that servant whom his lord,
when he cometh, shall find so doing."
So, Martin, there's a very special
blessing
on the watchman. Yeah.
He has to watch.
Who does he have to watch?
He must have to watch for his lord's
coming, so he has to warn.
And he has to watch what the thief is
doing so he can prepare to keep the
thief out of his house, right?
Now, what is the thief going to steal
from him?
His eternal life. Yeah.
He wants to rob him of eternal life. He
wants to sell him a bunch of lies.
So, you have to warn against the thief
and you have to say the Lord's coming is
soon. Is that a very popular message?
No.
And do people array themselves against
it and say, "Stop watching what's
happening on the other side of the wall.
Just preach love."
Yes.
Is that in harmony with this blessing?
No.
Okay.
Now,
just before they entered in the second
time,
there was another incident. Yes. And it
happened that
Baal Peor.
On the eastern side of Jordan, between
the river and the high tableland which
they had been traversing was also plain,
several miles in width
and extending some distance along the
river.
This sheltered valley had the climate of
the tropics. It's so nice to bathe in
the sun, isn't it?
Here flourished the shittim or acacia
tree, giving to the plain the name Vale
of Shittim.
It was here that the Israelites
encamped. And in the acacia groves by
the riverside, they found an agreeable
retreat.
But amid these attractive surroundings,
they were to encounter an evil more
deadly
than mighty host of armed men or the
wild beasts of the wilderness. That
country, so rich in natural advantages,
had been defiled by the inhabitants in
the public worship of Baal, the leading
deity.
The most degrading and iniquitous scenes
were constantly enacted. On every side
were places noted for idolatry and
licentiousness.
And the very names being suggestive of
the vileness and corruption of the
people.
Martin,
are we living in a world where vileness
and corruption are surrounding us every
single day? Definitely. Mhm. Yes.
These surroundings exerted a polluting
influence on the Israelites. Their minds
became familiar with the vile thoughts
constantly suggested.
Their life of ease and inaction produced
its demoralizing effects. And almost
unconsciously to themselves, they were
departing from God
and coming into a condition where they
would fall an easy prey to temptation.
Are we living in an antitype?
Definitely. If you look at
what's being fed to you through the
media, movies,
uh music.
And there were these beautiful ladies,
these Moabite and Midianite ladies with
their short little dresses.
And they enticed the Israelites.
So, that is a symbol of the other
churches that had lost their connection
with God enticing God's people.
Now, Martin, in 2017,
in October, in fact, on the 31st of
October 2017,
the world celebrated the 500th
anniversary of the Reformation.
Mhm.
But for the first time in the history
of this celebration,
there was an ecumenical
massive outreach where all the churches
participated
and the papacy and the reformed churches
celebrated the event together.
They had already announced that the
Reformation was at an end.
And that which Martin Luther feared the
most actually took place.
The Reformation, in a sense, formally
died. Yeah.
And they were dancing with Midianite
women
and Moabite women.
And all the churches participated
and sold out the law and the testimony.
A very sad sad event.
And we've been through that. So, that
means that Canaan must be just ahead,
right?
Yes.
It's important to realize that. Cuz
people are constantly asking us, "Where
are we
in the stream of time?"
Mhm.
We're on the banks of the Jordan.
Definitely.
And sitting in Shechem.
Correct. At this stage. Now, when that
Jordan
opened up,
when those priests put their foot in the
Jordan, and that water receded several
miles,
the Israelites were allowed to cross,
but they weren't allowed to come near
the ark.
No.
They didn't have holy flesh, you know
that.
They were still
subject.
You had to keep your distance. You had
to keep your distance. You had to have
your faith. They crossed across.
They took 12 stones out of the river and
erected a pillar.
And
they carried them. One representative
carried a big stone. They were strong
men.
Carried those stones across.
And the fear of God came into the other
people.
And even though they were in distress
because they took part in the first
Passover.
And they also were circumcised.
So, the other nations could have
attacked them, right?
But they fully healed.
And then they took Jericho. We've
discussed that.
We're on the verge of these events. Now,
here's an interesting statement that I
just want to
read.
"All who would have their names retained
in the book of life should now in the
few remaining days of their probation
afflict their souls before God by
sorrowful sin
and true repentance."
Martin, this is what we should be doing
in the time that we are living in. 100%.
You know, it it is the same
the three angels' messages. Yes. It the
first and second
Every time when you have to go through
this experience, you have to go through
get sorrow for sin and get true
repentance.
So, should we be preaching sustainable
development and climate change, or
should we be preparing a people for the
coming of the Lord? Preparing people for
the coming of the Lord and to enter
Canaan. Okay.
"There must be deep faithful searching
of heart. The light frivolous spirit
indulged by the majority of professed
Christians must be put away.
There's honest earnest warfare before
all who would subdue the evil tendencies
that strive for the mastery.
I think we're at that point as we said,
Mhm. when plagues will take God's people
away if they do not conform
and come into harmony with God's will.
"Solemn are the scenes connected with
the closing work of the atonement.
Momentous are the interests therein
involved.
The judgment is now passing in the
sanctuary above. 40 years has this work
been in progress. Martin, it's now much
longer than that, right?" Correct.
"Soon, none know how soon it will pass
to the cases of the living.
In the awful presence of God, our lives
are to come up in review.
At this time above all others, it
behooves every soul to heed the Savior's
admonition, 'Watch
and pray, for you know not
when the time is. Watch ye therefore,
lest coming suddenly find you
sleeping.'"
Martin,
is it possible
that we have been thinking that
we do not know the time, exactly the
hour, and all of these things applies
only to the second coming?
Doesn't it also apply to the close of
our personal probation?
That's correct.
"If therefore, thou shalt not watch, I
will come on thee as a thief, and thou
shalt not know what hour I will come
upon thee."
Revelation 3:3. This has nothing to do
with the second coming. No. It's got to
do with a close of probation for
Are we right with God? You know,
we are told that we will have an
experience which is akin to Jacob's
trouble.
And Jacob's trouble was,
"Are my sins forgiven?
I will not let you go lest you bless
me."
We need to have a time of serious soul
searching in the time that we are living
in. We need to make right with God. We
need to ask ourselves, "Have I fulfilled
the conditions? Have I come out of my
country?" Yes. Have I come out of my
family?
Have I come out of my family?
Have I come out in every aspect? Have I
separated myself from this world that is
heading towards a destruction similar to
that which struck Jericho?
Am I associated with the law and the
testimony?
That's right with God?
"How perilous is the condition of those
who growing weary of their watch turn to
the attractions of the world,
while the man of business is absorbed in
the pursuit of gain,
while the pleasure lover is seeking
indulgence, while the daughter of
fashion is arraying her adornments.
It may be in that hour that the judge of
the earth will pronounce the sentence,
'Thou art weighed in the balances and
are found wanting.'"
Serious issue. Very.
Serious
Life and death.
Eternal death. "Every soul that has
named the name of Christ has a case
pending at the heavenly tribunal.
It is a court week with us, and the
decision passed upon each case will be
final."
So, in other words, the coming as a
thief is the judgment and not
necessarily only the second coming.
Possible? Correct. It's very possible.
With that in mind, Martin,
is it time to give the trumpet a certain
sound? Definitely. It's time to stand on
the wall.
Is it time to get your life in order?
Yes. Is it time to wrestle with God Mhm.
and say, "I will not let you go unless
you bless me"?
Yes. Is it time to align yourself with
the law and the testimony?
Is it time to warn humanity of what is
coming?
Yes.
Have we progressed through the typology
to the point of the second entry?
Have we even passed Baal Peor? I think
so.
Have we danced with the Midianite women
and sat in their ecumenical councils and
pretended to be one of them? Yes. That
part is already actually
done. It's all done. So, what's left?
Going through the Jordan.
Will there be a plague like there was in
Baal Peor?
Definitely.
There will be a plague.
May God help us. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
we have passed through the streams of
time.
We are on the banks of the Jordan.
We have fulfilled the typology to the
letter.
We've wandered the antitypical 38 years.
We're there a second time. We've
completed the Baal Peor debacle.
And now
the ark will go before us,
the law and the testimony.
May we follow with
awe
and reverence.
Help us to get our lives in order.
And help us to be part of that group
that finally enters
into the country
that you will show us. In Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.
Thank you for watching this video.
To subscribe, click here.
When the bell appears,
click again to get notifications.
To watch the next video,
click here.
Thank you.